Try by day Joe Rogan podcast by night all day she and she's talking about,
this might be my last fight,
blah,
blah.
So I don't think she said that.
I think she said she's close a few less.
Which when you hear that right that you were talking about having one foot out
bowls.
So let's say she has two fights left,
maybe three,
who knows,
but she's not the same draw as Connor.
It's just not,
it's just new.
You look at the number,
she's not the same drawl,
but if she comes back beats and Amanda Nunez armbars or and then fight Cyborg
and then fights.
Holly Beats Beats Holly gets her rematch on Barnard as big as Connor.
You don't know that because as that happened,
he likes to bet Mr Joe Rody.
But here's the thing,
as these people,
when they're star gets more and more giant as Rhonda,
if Rhonda came back and started winning again,
her star would get more and more giant.
It would get bigger.
It would fuel more.
The more bodies she claims,
the more fuel for her fire we'll have.
That is what happens all the time.
It means it's pure speculation.
But when the way Connor has been winning,
she can win in spectacular fashion or the way she was winning when she fucked up
Alexis Davis and Sara Mcmann Merkin girls,
mark and convention custom one 15.
She could never make,
but you know what I'm saying?
Fuck No.
Why not?
She,
she's way too big,
but is she okay?
That'd be,
I mean,
yeah,
because she looks really,
really rushed away and sometimes that ain't,
that's,
this is nothing.
But um,
if for Conor and this,
and again,
I'm not rooting for favorites to,
I'm just saying it from business standpoint for Connor,
he's such a big draw.
Right?
What's going to help him in his negotiating power if Rhonda worked her lose this
next fight because then he's like,
I'm the only motherfucker in town.
You guys were just claiming me and Rhonda.
That's cool.
She's just lost.
I need my fucking money.
Well,
and by the way,
Ron has,
has a tough fight in front of her.
Amanda Nunez has,
God damn scary.
She's scary girl.
I was saying before Ronda lost to Holly,
I was saying she should've got the title fight and I said,
I said that,
I think she's the most dangerous one.
I was talking shit to you.
The way she stopped Sam Mcmann.
She cracks hanging I with that right hand.
She hits like a Mack truck.
She hits like a dude,
but she,
well,
Cyborg kits like a dude,
Amanda hits like a strong girl.
Big Difference.
Uh,
case like scary.
Like Tyrone Woodley with braids.
Let's be real.
She hits so hard and gets no love cause you so goddamn scary and can't make the
weight.
She also has a,
a better arsenal.
Like she'll throw kicks and knees.
Also Blackstone on the ground.
Think Amanda.
Amanda is,
but Amanda has lost on the ground before she got beat up by cats and gone on the
ground.
Correct.
Cyber Grip your limbs off.
But she's getting no love.
But um,
she's too big.
I know it's nine 55.
Well,
at one 50.
and again,
if,
like if they did that whole thing where I'm talking about the eliminated weight
cuts,
so there'd be two girls.
A cyborg would fight it like one 81 80.
It'd be,
it'd be hurt in that big ass girl.
Gabby can't see us.
He applies it to 80,
but that's all we got for,
you would have to cut weight to me.
Yeah.
We fight every other weekend.
Like Tim Silvia and Andrea Lawsky.
Let's do that every other weekend,
every other weekend because all we did is the old days.
But uh,
I,
I think for Rhonda,
the Amanda Nunez Fight stylist getting again,
we don't know.
We don't know where Rhonda is a mental state.
Is that,
but stylists gates a great matchup for Rhonda?
I think so.
Yeah.
I think if she comes ready prepared as a good camp,
she Mercer,
but don't you think that you look at the way she fucked up Misha Tate,
Eagle techgirl presents a lot of danger with those punches,
especially considering what happened with Holly and Ronda.
Yeah.
But yeah,
I think she presents a lot of,
Danes shoot a hundred percent Joe.
I think you Ryan that,
but I think her marching forward is the perfect antidote to get murked by Rhonda
cause she's like,
oh come get some of this judo though.
I'm an arm bar your ass if she marches forward,
which is really all she knows how to do.
You know what I'm saying?
It could be interesting.
It's a great fight either way,
but it's also interesting to see what we're round his head is now she's coming
back.
That's the x factor because if it's wrong 100% she beats her.
I think nine out of 10 times wrong words it,
I know but if it's Rhonda who's kind of our want to do movies,
I don't do this,
I this isn't for me.
You're going to get marked.
Cause that girl hit so hard.
Well what Rhonda has and what you want to has,
you know,
and not a whole lot of other women have it is one thing that they do where
they're really fucking good at it and then they have all those other stuff.
Correct.
Whereas like Paige vanzant has kind of learning the whole sport and she's
learning as she goes.
I,
she goes,
yeah,
but she,
what she does,
what Paige has is just toughness and she's hot.
Then I'll just take your sleep.
That helps.
Definitely helps.
But there's not other girls,
you know other than Valentina Valentina Shift Chanko yeah.
She's another one is bad ass.
Who is another super powerful striker.
Yeah.
I mean the way she handled Holly Holm standing up.
I know man.
Yeah.
Handled her.
Just countered or at will that,
that looping left hook,
that check hook that just throws off the right side.
Yeah.
She's another one but there's not,
they need more of those,
you know?
I agree.
That's where Mackenzie dern fits.
Exactly.
Come and do work and she's gorgeous.
But I'm saying if if college like,
listen,
I don't wish bad on anyone,
but Ronda were to lose.
We thrown a party in Ireland.
I'm the only show in town now.
Gimme my fucking piece of the pot.
Well nobody has that sort of personality that he has.
No one ever.
I think even he eclipses Ali.
I've seen clips is all of them.
I think he's,
he's bigger than Chael Sonnen for sure too.
As far as like his ability to,
uh,
Talk Shit.
Not Big on all of them,
but yeah,
I think he is.
I think he's better than Ali.
Ali Ali stood for a different thing,
right?
Like it's,
his message is more important.
Your fight for equal rights,
but he's also fighting to stop the Vietnam War act like this.
There's times he had several things could form that were bigger.
Correct.
Connor is white privilege.
Yeah.
His nice suits.
Nice suits.
If the government's not trying to send them over to fight in a war zone,
even a man,
they're not stripping his belt for how long?
Three years old fight.
Three fucking years.
And it's pretty prime.
It's prime.
It's like basically taking the belt from Conrad on the right.
Three years.
We'll see you soon.
Okay.